given a 5% year in your in creating
decrease in cogs and an increase in
leverage from 1.4 X to 2.8 eggs
we think we can increase free cash flow
by 67% and increase our underlying IRR
by 14% given a 5% are decreasing cogs
here on the earth
and an increase in the leverage from 1.4
s to 2.8 text feed believe we can
increase their CF by 67% and also
increase the underlying iro by 14% I'm
here to talk to you guys about
disruptive innovation a real paradigm
shift in solo mode we are Xen Hoover I
oh and we're here to change the world
I'm here to talk to you about disruptive
innovation Oh about solo mu we are then
over on Iowa and we are here to change
the world I'm here to talk to you about
disruptive innovation about in paradigm
shift in Solem oh we ours a new board on
IO and we're going to change the world
I smell a scent from the sea floor it's
very good for you to be neutrally
buoyant as you ascend from the sea floor
it's very critical for you to be
neutrally buoyant as you begin your
ascent from the sea floor that's
critical that you become neutrally
buoyant now I don't know about you but
you've just heard three of us say the
same thing three different times and yet
I'm guessing if you looked around the
room or if I told you the credibility of
each of the speakers may have differed
for example startup bro talking about
the private equity model unlikely to be
worth much Ryan talking about disruptive
innovation slightly more skeptical as
well and the gal in the suit telling you
what you should be doing when you're
diving to the ocean again not a source
of credibility we spend a lot of time in
this class talking about how my vocal
told well my physical gestures make a
difference on our presentation how they
affect how you react how they affect
what you learn how they fight what you
pay attention to what we haven't spent
as much time though Corina tried to in
the last presentation
he's talking about a tire and its effect
on us and the way you see it a tire has
three main issues
unlike most mark toy boats cars is real
and not just a product internet but
broadly a tire talks about every
interaction that we have from the broad
cultural thing to be aware of where you
are and who you're speaking to the
specific audience you're dealing with
whether it's an interaction or a meeting
but more importantly the effect that you
can have on yourself culture and
different societies have several
essential nuances about that culture for
example in the Western culture it is
encouraged to wear red as a power
statement on the other hand you do not
want to wear right to an Indian ready
how are attractive you may appear you do
not want to steal the show from the
bride because red is strictly the colour
of the bride in the indian reading
speaking about color let's look at some
of them strong personalities in this
world have influenced how they have
influenced the societies and the regions
right this is Margaret Thatcher and this
lot of thought that has gone in the
selection of the pub blue suit that she
wears blue is a universally accepted
color blue is a color that avoids evil
in creeks and blue is also the color of
Lord Krishna for Hinduism blue
represents holiness for church as you
can see there's lot of thought that has
gone into this understanding of the
cultural biases in making this position
further let's kind of drill down from
societies and countries to communities
and industries and see what attire means
as many of you may recognize this guy he
is Paul Graham who is the co-founder of
Y Combinator as you can see
he's speaking to a bunch of sorry guys
many of you could easily guess what
startup guys spec they're so busy with
their starting their businesses they
have no time to shop absolutely don't
care about price and rightfully here
Paul graha is talking to them in the
appropriate attire to inspire them and
to actually send his personal message of
what matters to him now trying to
connect to the community I would also
want to give you a word of caution right
for example just because you're talking
to a bunch of teenage skateboarders you
do not want to appear in the teenage
clothes unless you're someone like
rodney Mullen who is actually the
greatest street skateboarder in the
world and thus it's essential to be
authentic also in terms of what you are
as you bring your perception to the
audience and if you're authentic you can
not only build your brand there's lot
more you can do as your apprentice Steve
Jobs but has some mystic dressing he not
he not only made a statement of him
being a unconventional SIBO he actually
said of the culture of what Apple is to
me how many of you remember what Apple
was before 1998 look at all his keynotes
from 1998 all the way to 2010 it's the
same pair of denim jeans it's the same
track turtleneck and also the same pair
of sneakers he surely wanted to create a
culture for simplicity and also being
unconventional that said let's look at
what you want to create an impact on
whether it be industry or was it just a
bunch of people like you in the room
let's talk about what's the impact we
want to create with attire
another so we spent some time talking
about culture and its effect on people
but there's also effect on the specific
audience you deal with for example this
is a fact you know this I know this and
the scientific research backed you up
Allison over book found that forty five
percent of people think that someone
wearing glasses appears more intelligent
a study in Switzerland found that even
when you're dealing with random
strangers if they are wearing glasses
you think they are smarter with no other
evidence to the contract for those of
you who are looking at some point in
your careers to run into trouble with
the law and I'm looking at some of the
private equity kids here one of the
really interesting findings of the
american journal of forensic psychology
is that defendants who wear glasses are
less likely to be found guilty than
those who don't
more importantly these same defendants
are perceived by juries who again have
listened to them lie and steal for god
knows how long to be significantly
smarter and more trustworthy is any
rational basis to this absolutely not am
i going to wear these in the
presentation absolutely
aside from that though there are
downsides as well everyone's seen the
hollywood version where you know Anne
Hathaway clearly is a giant nerd when
she has glasses and suddenly is a
shining princess without but women in
particular as a game Carina talked about
earlier had different issues with the
tire I'm guessing every woman here knows
that she is judged more harshly for her
attire than men are what is interesting
and perhaps sad is that women are judged
more harshly on their time by other
women a study again in the UK pointed
out had 129 women look at a panel of
images these images varied on two
dimensions one some of the women were
labeled as high status aka managers and
the other one were labeled as
receptionist the second dimension is
some of the high status and some of the
low status women had clothes that would
describe a slightly more provocative
provocative here meaning a skirt that
was half an inch shorter than the other
half what do you think we found for the
receptionist no difference the
competence was just the same
whether they were wearing a slightly
shorter skirt or not for the high status
women though they were judged is
supremely harshly to the extent that
their skirt was sugar is there any basis
for this absolutely not is this fair
definitively not doesn't mean you
shouldn't pay attention to it no way you
absolutely should but this isn't limited
that both of them are actors both of
them play doctors and yet if you look at
America and pull them on who was more
competent the guy on the Left would
definitely win a University of Michigan
matter study found that in 21 of 30
studies doctors wearing white lab coats
meant that patients thought they were a
more competent be more trustworthy and
seemed more likely to ride them with
better health care going forward once
again the point here isn't about the
facts underlying it but in the world of
evidence-based medicine they said that
the patient feels better about
themselves is a big deal so that action
takeaway from this study was that they
told doctors to put on white lab coats
whether they had them or not just
because patients felt better about but
we've talked about culture and we've
talked about others the really
fascinating impact but the stuff is what
your clothing can do for you
so I want to talk to you about the
impact your clothing can have on your
self perception and self-confidence so
many of you recognize this man but I
want to remain culturally sensitive for
those of you who didn't grow up in the
United States
his name is mr. Rogers and the Mister
Rogers used to be the host of a
children's television show and he would
start every show by walking into his
house changing his sweater
sitting down taking off his loafers and
putting on some sneakers that were
essentially what he liked to wear in his
house and what he was doing was changing
his clothing from what he felt
comfortable and in the outside world to
what he felt comfortable in in his house
sorry and it's it's kind of logical
Solomon and Douglas did a study where
they they found that when your clothing
your attire matches your situation there
are positive psychological consequences
many of you thought I flub there that
was in
but as Adak was mentioning about the
perception of that people have about
glasses its internal as well so a study
was done where the essentially two
groups were broken apart one of those
groups was given glasses and they were
asked to take an IQ test the group that
was given glasses rated their
performance more highly a sign of
self-confidence despite the fact that
they didn't actually perform better but
there are other studies which actually
show there is an increase in performance
when you do dress kind of dress up
there's an interesting nuance to this
though so when you're wearing as a
general a generality when you're wearing
business formal attire you feel more
trustworthy you feel more competent and
you feel more authoritative when you're
wearing casual clothing you feel
friendlier and when your preference
matches what you're wearing those
attributes are amplified so for example
let's say I'm a finance guy and I need
to go present at a start-up I'm probably
not gonna go ah decotis style because
I'm not gonna be in my comfort zone what
I probably want to hit is that business
casual zone where I'm very I'm more
aligned with my level of comfort in
terms of the attire I prefer to wear but
I'm not alienating myself from my
audience so in terms of choosing the
attire that is most appropriate for your
presentation we ask that you follow the
reverse pyramid method
you start out widely with a culture that
you're presenting to you narrow down to
the your direct audience those others
you're going to be interfacing with and
then look at yourself what are you most
comfortable with
you